you ready for this there's the biggest
race of your life I'm not giving you
everything that you wanted
let's go back to see your father cicadas
going on a killing spree we need to stop
this guy
no know what your name will be like for
your there is a killer still at large in
our city that man hurt your child if
you're not careful that anger will
consume you the same way it can seem to
him no it's mine
he never stops chili I thought my future
would be just
you're not gonna watch anybody else be
broken by this mania let's go get her
flash returns with an all-new episode
this Tuesday at 8/7 central on the CW
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new flash footage to break down
episode 10 is airing next week there's
like five different storylines going on
in this episode just based on all the
trailer footage that they've released so
far there's a new brand of that flash
ring giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from this trailer on the
video we'll just break this down based
on the five different storylines so
first big one is obviously this trailer
is hyping up flash versus cicada he's
slowly be getting stronger and stronger
as he's beginning sicker and sicker as
like the meta tech the Dark Matter
starts to permeate the rest of his body
we don't really know what he's gonna
look like when it completely takes over
his body but is presumably he'll be all
powerful by the time we get to Nora's
time period in the future where you see
them walking around the flash museum but
I think part of the metaphor that
they're playing into is that he's acting
like a monster and by the end of the
season he will look like a monster based
on the way the dark matter is changing
his body the dark matter that gave
cicada his powers is the same dark
matter to the gate bury his powers so
technically cicada does have ties to the
Speed Force and his dagger does absorb
Speed Force energy which you know
remember that that'll be important for
later this season but he's not turning
into any kind of dark flash or anything
like that it's just pure dark matter
meta situation where he's just absorbing
energy and becoming stronger love the
way they wade into the really WTF stuff
in present day to where Barry opens the
trailer by saying getting ready for the
race of your life and you see Nora
training inside the flash lab then the
reversal of the funny moment with them
on the ice just trying to have a nice
father/daughter moment just because Nora
has probably never ice-skated in her
life before you see Nora get her ass
handed to her a couple times during the
trailer in different instances so the
way they cut it is a little misleading
like you see Barry cradling her on the
ground here in broad daylight but then
later at night in a different shot you
see her soaked this giant explosion that
has nothing more to do with the car
stuff The Fast and the Furious stuff
that we saw in the last big trailer so
when Nora says I can't feel my legs
if you don't remember that's actually a
mere four when Barry lost the use of his
legs I think it was in season two after
episode six
seriously you got your ass kicked I
can't feel my leg oh yes you can't bear
you'll make it so much progress yep six
whole steps someone gave me a bozo
button hey give yourself some credit you
just broke your back yeah a normal
person would have been paralyzed the
rest of his life
how long until I'm fully healed the
initial MRI I took a week ago showed a
complete dislocation of the t12 to l1
inner space of the thoracolumbar
junction but this is the MRI I took this
morning it's remarkable but you're
almost completely healed I'm still
having trouble breathing that's totally
normal with a spinal injury he had to
use a wheelchair because zoom hurt his
spine so bad but because their flashes
they regenerate way faster so obviously
Nora will get the use of her legs back
pretty quickly but this is all just
supposed to play into the idea that
Barry is worried about his daughter so
he starts to get more and more pissed
off the way that cicada
got pissed off so it's a mirror for
cicadas storyline because of the dark
matter satellite that hurt his daughter
who's been in the hospital since before
the beginning of the season there's a
couple SummerSlam WWE level fights
between Barry and cicada in this pool
hall like you see him grab the chair
just trying to rack it right across the
kada cicada picks him up and flings him
across the pool table there just a
reminder that cicada is now physically
more powerful like remember every time
we've seen him in the post-credits of
all the last couple of episodes he's
always like squeezing metal bars and
just reminding you how crazy strong he
is second big storyline is obviously all
the reverse-flash and nora stuff in the
distant future there's only a little bit
of that in this trailer but there's like
two separate reverse-flash things going
on because you have flash museum in the
near-term future then you have all the
eobard thawne reverse-flash iron Heights
stuff with Nora in the distant future
I've worried that a couple videos about
the whole Silence of the Lambs Hannibal
Lecter stuff going on between them but I
think part of the idea is that by the
end of the season they will achieve
their goal things will totally go off
the rails in an unexpected but like
really cool way but there's so much of
him with Nora this season that it seems
like they're foreshadowing a fight
between the two of them by the end of
the season like obviously he's gonna try
and break out of prison at some point
and Nora will have to stop him the core
of their storyline all about saving
Barry from crisis trying to find out how
much they can save the timeline
and in a more psychological sense as the
producers say reverse-flash pondering
his enduring legacy and potentially
turning over a new leaf but I don't
think any of us believe that like he's
reverse-flash ultimately at the end of
the day even if he tries to do something
good short-term long-term he'll show his
true colors yellow turn run do something
selfish and obviously become the villain
that we all know him to be but don't
forget about all the crisis stuff that's
happening next year when you're watching
the eobard thawne Nora stuff because of
the way that they're messing with the
timeline third big storyline is Barry
and iris in the flash Museum in the
near-term future when noir is a little
girl sitting here reading the flash
comic with all the flash merch all
around her in that weird-looking dummy
version of reverse flash walking around
they just like some weird cosplayer
scaring people walking through the
museum can you imagine the briefing that
they would give whatever college kid
they would pay to climb into that
costume to walk around the museum please
don't tell people that reverse flash
killed Barry's mother it'll bun them out
and they won't buy as much merch we want
them to buy more merch I believe the
comic that Nora is reading is a cicada a
comic from the Geoff Johns run because a
lot of the comics that they pull from
are the geoff johns era but also we're
doing cicada on the TV show this year so
there's a lot of cicada comic book
Easter eggs I do love the imagery at the
end of the broken flash quote unquote
you know big metaphor for what's
happening at present-day cicada breaking
the flash when Nora drops the figure and
it shatters on the ground at her feet
the only reason I would think that they
would go to the flash museum like you
see iris in the Hall of villains here is
probably them just trying to get more
information about cicada from the future
and then they just accidentally bump
into Nora and they try to avoid being
spotted by anybody like hey wait a
minute you look kind of like Barry Allen
you look kind of like a younger version
of iris West fourth big story line is
all the fast and furious car stuff with
the new meta Silver Ghost played by this
girl here she is playing a comic book
character but she has no relation to the
actual comic book character they're just
borrowing the name so her powers and her
backstory are a little bit different
then we also have weather [ __ ] who's
also back like I talked about in the
last trailer so she's sort of like the
new stand in for weather wizard although
I'm sure that he'll always come back and
guest star at least once per season but
five there's also supposed to be a
separate Caitlin Cisco storyline she's
also got like her ongoing killer frost
stuff going on separately but
guess them just continuing a bunch of
story arcs and sort of setting up what
the energy is going to be for the next
block of episodes not necessarily the
entire rest of the season but give you
an idea for the next several episodes
because I do think that by the end of
the season there'll be some sort of post
credit scene which will tee up what's
going on with crisis on Infinite Earths
so let me know in the comments what your
favorite WTF moment from this and any
other Easter eggs that you spotted that
I didn't mention in the video I'll name
a new winner when I post a new DC video
there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff happening this week click here for
a brand new Avengers endgame and Captain
Marvel footage listening to Kevin Feige
talk about a whole bunch of cool stuff
and click here to rewatch that opening
scene from Young Justice season 3 thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]